JESSICA HARROP: Hi, I'm Jessica.
And I'm going to be talking
about a chemical demonstration
today that I like
to call let it snow.
MIT's Dr. John Dolhun--
here he is-- and his
assistant, Arielle,
are going to perform two
magic tricks involving
super absorbent polymers.
Let's watch as they show us
the first one at the Cambridge
Science Festival.
[WHOOSH]
JOHN DOLHUN: And
what I'm going to do
is I'm going to pour some
water into the beaker
that she's holding.
And you keep your
eyes on the beaker.
Bring it down just a bit.
Hold it firmly.
Turn it to-- we are making snow.
We're making snow
today, Arielle.
ARIELLE LUBIN: Oh, boy.
It's so cold and wet.
It's just like real snow.
Look!
[WHOOSH]
JESSICA HARROP:
So what happened?
Well, Arielle was
holding a beaker
containing some sodium
polyacrylate, which
is a polymer.
Now a polymer is a
big molecule that's
a chain of repeating units.
This is the unit.
And this is what it
looks like in a chain.
Now, different chains are
held together by cross links.
The et cetera just
means that this could
be thousands of carbons long.
This is just a small part of
the chain and the polymer.
Now when water is
added to the polymer,
it wants to rush into
the material because
of the presence of so many
sodium and carboxylate ions.
The water displaces the
sodium ions leaving negatively
charged carboxylic ions.
These repel each other
and the repulsion
causes the polymer, which
starts out wound together,
to unwind, swell, and stretch.
The cross lengths, which connect
the polymer chains together,
prevent them from breaking
apart in the water.
And the fake snow that's
created is the same snow
they use in
Hollywood movie sets.
Now, let's watch Dr. Dolhun and
Arielle turn this same polymer
into something
totally different.
[WHOOSH]
JOHN DOLHUN: OK, so I've got
another beaker she's holding.
And I'm going to pour some
water in it and observe.
Turn it over, Arielle.
You don't have to hold
your hand under the hole.
That's the same polymer.
Only this time
the polymer is not
as cross-linked
as the first one.
It's more of the
straight chain polymer.
And it can absorb many more
times its weight in water.
You'll recognize this.
This is the diaper polymer.
You know now, right?
[WHOOSH]
JESSICA HARROP: So Dr.
Dolhun uses the same polymer
with a different amount
of cross linking.
The sodium polyacrylate
that makes diaper gel
has fewer cross-links
and therefore can
absorb more water than the
sodium polyacrylate that
turned into snow.
Overall, this polymer can
absorb up to 800 times
its own weight in distilled
water and about 30
times its own weight in urine.
It's the main ingredient
in baby diapers
used to keep the baby dry.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hope you enjoyed the video
and I'll see you next time.